et bien bonjour à vous tous chers jeunes
et bien venez samedi dernier nous étions
en direct de l'avant première du film
tous en scène au grand rex
quelle ambiance découvrez notre
reportage exclusif et fait connaissance
avec les voix françaises petit coucou
c'est jennifer bonjour ces patrimoines
salut c'est le dit martelly
bonjour c'est laurent gerra fallu se
fâcha bienvenue à l'avant première de
tous en scène
c'est hilarant c'est très profond ça
parle de beaucoup de choses elodie
macler et sasha thème les messages les
chansons tout effort maintenant si vous
voulez vraiment avoir le pig epower faut
les vendre
c'est un truc qui va vous faire du bien
ça
[Musique]
des diagonales
allez sorte
c'était vraiment trop bien on a envie de
danser on a envie de chanter
on a eu de s'amuser quoi vraiment
excellent les personnages super
attachant
c'est hyper drôle on soigne pas une
seconde ça m'a fait rire et chansons
était sympa donc vraiment fait très bien
bon moment c'était génial très très beau
film est une belle leçon de vie
[Musique]
la la la bonté prémont grand jas je suis
prêt de chez près
[Musique]
le film est très fort et très drôle très
émouvant et puis il nous plonge dans un
milieu qu'on connaît bien cette chanson
est fait pour toi waouh
vous lisez dans mon pauvre esprit d'ado
à livre ouvert quand j'ai vu le film
j'ai chanté du début jusqu'à la fin
ça va très bien merci
fo c'est un peu the voice des animaux
rosita est toujours là oui oui oui je
suis là on s'est beaucoup amusés à le
faire excellent ça va habilement des les
choses
attendez vous voulez qu'on chante
ensemble tous les deux genres tous les
deux toi et moi en web et enfin mettre
les piments là non le dessin animé très
réussi super beau très amusant avec des
personnages très attachants extrêmement
bien dessinés dans tous les sens du
terme et des supers moments d'émotion il
ya des super beau message et c'est ce
qu'il ya de bien quand on a touché le
fond c'est qu'il ne reste plus qu'une
issue on doit non mais c'est génial
c'est un film qui pourra parler je pense
pas qu'au petit là quelque chose
d'extrêmement touchant extrêmement
mature et il ya une vraie histoire
je pense que les gens vont être réactif
dans la salle ça va être chouette à voir
la la la bonté prémont grand jas je suis
prêt de chez près cinq habitants de
cette ville a une chance de devenir une
star grâce à notre concours de chant
vous allez très pourri fait par le pi 10
po comme ça va très bien merci
fo
si vous voulez devenir des stars et
gagner 100 mille dollars vous allez
devoir travailler plus dur que vous ne
l'avez jamais fait toute votre vie
c'était très mauvais ou et johnny ne
vais pas là oui c'était une répétition
papa je veux pas faire partie de son
gang ce que je veux sept chanteurs
comment j'ai fait pour avoir un fils
comme toi c'est élise était ministre
c'est du toit du complot sans toi tu
peux y arriver oui ou non je suis là
qu'est ce qui se passe ici
il faut jamais laisser la peur nous
empêcher de faire ce qu'on aime c'est ce
qui l'a bien quand on a touché le fond
c'est qu'il ne reste plus qu'une issue
on doit remonter
c'est mon fiston
elle est hyper du sel là ouais non c'est
clair je peux pas bouger sont terrorisés
allez sorte
je suis désolé
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi vous n'êtes pas en train de
répéter cette fois c'est mort ils m'ont
carrément accusé d'être égocentrique
je sais même pas ce que ça veut dire
[Musique]